muriel bolle avait accusé en 84 bernard
laroche avait affirmé avoir assisté à
l'enlèvement du petit grégory muriel
bolle a défendu aujourd'hui la mémoire
de son beau frère
elle l'a innocenté l' affaire grégory
reste toujours mystérieuse dominique
verdeilhan gilles dobler tranquillement
sereinement assurément muriel bolle fait
son entrée au 19e jour du procès en 84
muriel bolle avait 15 ans 9 ans plus
tard la petite fille rousse et mère de
deux enfants et chômeuses
on ne veut pas m'embaucher tant que la
sphère ne sera pas finie dit elle et
elle compte sur la cour d'assises pour
rétablir sa vérité
il s'attend pour m'expliquer ce que
personne me laisse le temps d'expliquer
qui suis-je à dire muriel bolle persiste
et signe le 16 octobre à 17 heures j'ai
pris le car à bruyères en sortant de
l'école 20 minutes plus tard je suis
arrivé à la maison bernard laroche était
avec son fils sébastien sur les genoux
première contradiction de la journée
souligné par le président bernard
laroche a déclaré être arrivé
après muriel bolle mais dans l'après
midi l'assurance affichée le matin
s'estompe car est venue l'heure des
contradicteurs
jean-marie galmiche le conducteur du car
et catégories muriel n'est pas monté
dans son véhicule
sonia personne est formel muriel est
monté dans une voiture conduite par un
homme pour nelly de mange
en revanche elle y était dans le car les
gendarmes sont revenus plusieurs fois
parce que j'étais la seule à donner
cette version dit elle
l'un d'eux m'a traitée de menteuse
confie muriel dans un sanglot j'ai eu
peur
les gendarmes ont menacé d'aller en
maison de correction si je disais le
contraire
le premier jour de son procès jean marie
villemin avait prononcé qu'une seule
phrase
j'attends une chose que muriel dise la
vérité sur la mort de mon enfant il
reste à jean marie villemin et aux douze
jurés de la cour d'assises de dijon plus
d'une semaine de confrontation pour
qu'il se forge une intime conviction